[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory
today's video is going to be a little
bit different than normal as we're going
to be taking a look at the filming
locations for some of the most iconic
scenes of the Harry Potter franchise if
you're anything like me and when you
watch an iconic scene in a film your
brain probably starts to think about
where it was that scene was set you
can't help but be curious at what place
in reality was reshaped to create the
magic Thea witnessing on screen though I
loved the books daily the Harry Potter
films have a very special place in my
heart in part due to the fact that I was
very close in age to the actors that
played Harry Ron and Hermione as I grew
older the films were gradually released
and it gave me the opportunity to
revisit these same characters who had
aged just as I had this made them very
special magical and I honestly felt that
all four directors of the Harry Potter
films did an excellent job at keeping
this magic alive with all of the other
positives of the Harry Potter franchise
aside this magical feeling the film's
exuded could definitely not have been
achieved without carefully chosen
filming locations which are the topic of
this video I'm not going to be taking a
look at every filming location but I'm
going to be taking a look at some of the
most notable particularly from the first
film of course if you guys enjoy this
type of video I am always capable of
making more I'm not going anywhere you
just have to let me know with that said
let's get things started
first let's jump right back to the very
beginning of the films and take a look
at the iconic platform at 9 and 3/4 if
you don't know what platform learning
3/4 is but I don't really know what to
tell you you may be on the wrong video
it is of course the platform in which
students board the Hogwarts Express the
Scarlett's steam engine that brings
students to and from Hogwarts
it's accessed by walking straight
through the barrier between platforms 9
and 10 platform 9 and 3/4 was of course
filmed at Kings Cross station on the
edge of central London it's an active
railway station but at the real station
you will find that platforms 9 and 10
are separated by tracks
for filming platforms 4 & 5 were
remembered 9 and 10 and at the station
today you'll find the hidden access to
platform 9 and 3/4 complete with half a
luggage cart disappearing into the wall
the entrance to Kings Cross station in
the film was shot at the st. Pancras
Renaissance Hotel also located in London
next up we're going to be taking a look
at Diagon Alley the famous cobblestone
shopping area that allows witches and
wizards to purchase all of their magical
supplies this is one of the first places
that Hagrid brings harry opening his
eyes to the magic of the Wizarding World
in reality Diagon Alley is also known as
Leadenhall market the markets dating
back to the 14th century it's located in
London and operates as an actual market
to this day access to primarily via the
main entrance on Gracechurch Street once
you've made it past platform known in
three quarters and have amassed all of
your school supplies in Diagon Alley
next shall be boarding the Hogwarts
Express the train that transports
students to Hogwarts it runs between
Kings Cross station and Hogsmeade
stationed and makes the trip
approximately six times per year or more
if necessary it's on the Hogwarts
Express that Harry first meets his
faithful companions Ron and Hermione in
the films we see the train navigating
through the countryside scooting past
beautiful greenery and even a body of
water most notably we see the whole
quilt Express travelling over a bridge
this bridge is known as the Glenfinnan
viaduct found in Scotland it's located
on the West Highland line in Glenfinnan
in venecia Scotland it is the longest
concrete railway bridge in Scotland at
416 yards and crosses the river Finan at
a height of 100 feet the viaduct also of
looks that then Finan Monument and the
waters of Loch Shiel when you finished
your journey on the train your next
destination as a new student is a school
that you may have heard of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
huckel's is of course the castle where
all students attend to their magical
studies and in the words of Ruby's
Hagrid
Hogwarts is the finest School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in the
while the precise location of the school
is never revealed to us due to it being
unpossible in reality we know that
hogwarts school was filmed across a
multitude of different filming locations
perhaps most notably these locations
include Durham Cathedral Alma castle and
Gloucester Cathedral a behemoth tasks
like creating a set for an entire school
is no easy feat so multiple locations
were needed to establish a diverse array
of interior and exterior shots Durham
Cathedral was founded in 1093 and is
home to the shrine of Saint Cuthbert the
Cathedral was proclaimed a world
heritage site in 1986 Durham Cathedral
is of course located in Durham England
and boasts a 218 foot central tower with
144 foot Western towers darn cathedrals
used for both interior and exterior
shots of Hogwarts Alnwick Castle is a
castle and country house in all awake in
the English county of Northumberland it
is the second largest inhabited castle
in England and was used primarily for
exterior shots of Hogwarts it's also
been used as a filming location for many
many of the films and TV shows including
Ivanhoe Robin Hood Star Trek and more
and lastly Gloucester Cathedral is a
Cathedral located in Gloucestershire
England standing north of the city near
the river 7 I've actually had the
pleasure of visiting Gloucester
Cathedral personally and it was
absolutely spectacular in person it is
420 feet long 144 feet wide a defined
central tower at the 15th century rising
to the height 225 feet and topped by for
delicate integrals a famous landmark the
Cathedral was used for many of Hogwarts
interior shots and that's it for this
video if you enjoyed this type of
content then let me know down in the
comment section below
I'd be more than happy to cover some
more of the filming locations if you
guys are into it until next time you're
a wizard Harry
[Music]